islamic terrorism is all a figment
of your imagination
islamic terrorism we can't talk about it
because we all know how we'll be painted
if we do
i hate all muslims because they
they blow crap up and when given the
choice between having my
my crap blown up or my crap
not blown up i often prefer to
to not have my crap blown up
prefer to keep my my crap intact
that's pretty much why i hate anybody
who's not white christian
besides islamic terrorism isn't really
that big of a threat
we're not running a war on terror but an
overseas contingency operation remember
tell that to amar farooq abdulmutallab
the man who recently tried to blow up a
plane on the way to detroit by stuffing
his crotch with p-e-t-n
hey amar are those explosives in your
pocket are you just happy to see me
oh no no it's a bum and despite what
napolitano tried to tell you our
security
isn't what saved us but the god-given
gift of islamic terrorist ineptitude
see instead of blowing the plane up he
lit himself
ablaze
that's sort of a risky move too
considering that the islamic view of
heaven is a much more physical one than
the traditional image we've seen painted
i know what the way to go right imagine
my virgin surprise
you know i'm going to hell aren't i
yeah okay that way
for crying out loud these guys are the
marvin harrys of the terrorist world
and that's a good thing considering how
the current administration is choosing
to deal with
this scum why can't we use the words
islamic terrorism everyone knows that
the first step towards fixing a problem
is acknowledging that you have one
okay so this last quarter we've been
incurring far too many costs
here um we're not supposed to use the
word cost
okay uh expenses can't
say that either expenditures
then nope well uh
what can i say daryl are there grumpy
numbers
grouchy points or uh giggle digits
so my first question of the new year to
you is do you think that we should be
able to acknowledge the enemy we
fight in islamic terrorism or do you
think that using the words are just
inflammatory as always be sure to let me
know
now i say that whether it's a fire
crutcher or a random dude who disappears
in a new jersey airport
let's refer to these islamic terrorist
scumbags as nothing more than a human
excrement that they are
and show the world that we are no longer
afraid to stand up to bullies and
tyrants
oh come on don't act like you're not
impressed
you